i'm
interested to know what your opinion is
about whether marijuana
is an addictive thing to some people
yeah that's a good answer yeah there's
some people just some people yeah
of course it would be it's that feeling
yeah i i'm addicted but i'm not
physically addicted
right you know like i can take it or
leave it
you know right it doesn't matter to me
right you don't get physical withdrawals
without it
no but there's like a habitual addiction
yeah last night was weird for me i'm
doing what i'm doing now you know i'm
doing my fan mail
and all of a sudden i felt this like i
was
high on something
and i i you know because sometimes i
don't remember
you know especially with the virus with
the virus you know every once in a while
go oh wow am i getting that virus then i
realized
oh no i smoked out
that's so so last night
i said oh i i
i couldn't walk i was sort of falling
over
you know and because i i practiced a
tango walk that's
that's my exercise it was a special way
to do a tango walk
and excuse me
and so uh bless you so i couldn't figure
out you know
i had lost my belt and i and i know i
didn't get
high and i couldn't figure out what it
was so i said well
i better get high
then i'll know and so i smoked up
and i got too high and when i get too
high
it's betty by his time you know
and so i went to bed went to bed had a
nice sleep woke up
fine everything's fine but it's uh
yeah you know
being a bodybuilder i learned a lot
about diet and about my body
and it's it's cool
you know what what what i really used it
for
now is the spiritual side
i've been smoking and meditating
not so much meditating thinking
yeah thinking in fact in fact i haven't
meditated for a long time
you know because uh
i i found out something you know that
you don't have to
all you have to do it's your mind see
marijuana can
really affects the mind and the way it
does it puts you in the moment
you know and that's why whatever you're
doing in the moment
it's enhanced like if you're in the art
gallery for instance all of a sudden
you're you're seeing
art that you've never seen before ah
[ __ ] but the the thing is about
marijuana it it keeps you on me anyway
uh boils things down to the essence
you know people the thing is about
meditation
uh it's good if that's what you do you
know but
just like in the christian bible says
you know
that you don't have to make repeat these
things over and over and over again you
know
as if you know the christian bible they
kind of talk bad about
repeating repeating uh mantras
you know
you know okay yeah all that really does
is stop
it's it stops your your mind from going
other places
you know it keeps gives your mind a bone
to chew on
but all you have to do that's what i
tell everybody
is change your thought you can't have
two thoughts in your head at the same
time
you think you can but you can't so
whenever trouble or anything arises
think of god that's the most powerful
thought you could have
and that's it don't don't think of what
you need or what you want because
it's cool god will be uh
uh you know all you have to do is think
of god
and people said to me you know when i
did the movie against god they
said did you talk to god today i said no
i never talked to god
i only listen all right
thanks so much for watching this clip
and if you drink
coffee you need a mug shot mug
that's my first ever mug shot and this
mug is available on
amazon as well as at stevo.com so go
ahead and click the link in the
description below
this is what you're going to find and
grab yourself a mug shot
mug yeah dude
yeah dude